Oscar's costume was incredibly difficult
to build first we start with these very
detailed costume sketches then all the
fabrics he wore were created and made
especially for him they had 13 moving
pieces to it there was his layers upon
layers to give it very complex look it
was 3d printed there was gauntlets there
was gloves there was leggings there was
wild boots chest piece we wanted him to
feel larger than other people in the
movie physically we wanted him to have
that sort of ancient mythic godlike look
to him and all of that's a little more
sci-fi and radical than we've done in
the movies to date and action one of the
challenges that the fabrication
department at Legacy effects had to do
was create this fantastic looking armor
that looks heavy looks metal looks
rugged but make it quick to put on fast
to take off as cool as possible all the
stuff you need to consider that there's
a human in this costume there's also
very uncomfortable Oscar constantly was
very hot so he had cold water piped in
through tubes whenever we were done
shooting a sequence we would have
someone with a tank full of cold water
that would plug him into I basically had
a pit crew and they would just come in
and try to take it off in between takes
and they got so fast with it